there's a famous tale about a
pumpkin-headed demon that for many
captures the spirit of halloween
washington irving's headless horseman i
actually think there's a much scarier
headless monster with potential to keep
you up at night year round one that
began the folklore of my ancestors the
Irish duel on
I'm dr. Emily Zarqa and this is monstre
before we really get into the legend of
the Dullahan let's address the pumpkin
in the room the Headless Horseman of
Sleepy Hollow Washington Irvine wrote
the short story The Legend of Sleepy
Hollow in 1820 in it Ichabod Crane and
his rival Brom bones both fall in love
with Katrina Van Tassel because of her
great beauty and her large inheritance
one night after a rejection from Katrina
a drunken Ichabod is chased down by a
black cloaked figure on horseback and
then mysteriously vanishes only his hat
and broken pieces of a pumpkin left
behind with Ichabod out of the picture
Katrina marries Brom and the townspeople
are led to believe
Ichabod was carried away by a terrifying
Headless Horseman of supernatural speed
and strength most of us know the
Headless Horseman through children's
books or the Disney version there's also
that movie that's loosely based on the
story which has a lot of issues
including the steamin ization of women
well let's move on I believe it's not
only possible but likely that Irving
knew about the Irish Dullahan before
writing his famous spooky story his
mother and father were immigrants with
an English and Scottish heritage he had
a Scottish nanny
he traveled extensively across Europe he
was friends with noted author Sir Walter
Scott who was indeed Scottish so it's
not hard to imagine that Irving was
exposed to Celtic culture we could also
give credit to her veins other possible
European influences like Tam O'Shanter
by Robert Burns and the wild Huntsman by
goat freed Auguste burger both poems I
have supernatural horse juices basically
Irving took the concept of a headless
horseman from the Dullahan and added
elements that would make it more
frightening for his target audience
Americans
Irving uses the name of an actual town
in the United States and his villain is
called the galloping Hessian a reference
to the real German soldiers hired by the
British to fight in the Revolutionary
War who were known for their extreme
violence so urban takes fact and adds it
to his fiction saying quote it is said
by some to be the ghost of hessian
trooper whose head had been carried away
by
in some nameless battle during the
Revolutionary War the story of the
Headless Horseman in popular culture
usually has horses nighttime journeys
carriages and graveyards all things that
we find in dullahan legends but what's
unique about the Dullahan that's
different from other monsters is that it
doesn't actually kill you you might get
your eyes whipped out because that's a
thing they do but your life isn't
immediately in peril but the dullahan is
though is a grave forewarning if you see
one it's not good you or someone you
love will die or suffer in subterra Bowl
horrible eyeless way the dullahan story
first appeared in writing in the 19th
century in collections of Irish folklore
like fairy legends and traditions of the
south of Ireland by Thomas Crofton
croaker
and fairy and folk tales of the iris
peasantry by WB Yeats which introduced
Irish legends to the masses
the Dullahan can be either male or
female always travels by horse and is
headless most of the time their head is
still with them sometimes it floats
close to their bodies or is tucked under
their arm or is even inside their pocket
in many stories the horse is headless to
dullahan can also travel in packs and
the harvest dinner a carriage full of
headless passengers is driven by a
headless driver and pulled by headless
horses other account to the Dullahan
show them in the company of banshees
racing human writers and even bowling
with their own skull now that would be
the party of a lifetime in the aptly
named the death coach a dullahan wields
a long whip and drives a team of
headless horses his carriage wheels are
made from human thigh bones and the
carriage is lit by two hanging skulls in
some versions the whip that carry is
even more horrifying it's actually made
from a human life the Dullahan is the
personification of death the headless
corpse was something the Irish were all
too familiar with a predominantly
Catholic culture there are many stories
and paintings that depict martyred
Saints walking around carrying their
heads as a symbol of how they were
executed even before Catholicism was
introduced in the fourth century early
Celts would take and preserve the heads
of slain enemies to dehumanize them they
believed the head was where the soul was
located so removing the head damages the
spirit decapitation was practice in
medieval Ireland both in battle and as a
form of punishment during late Tudor
rule the British government even offered
head money to anyone who could present
the head of a known rebel to the crown
there are written accounts of these
beheadings and also archaeological
evidence across Ireland both male and
female skeletons have been discovered
with their heads forcibly removed
this might explain tales of headless
monsters but what about the headless
horses well the Irish believed one of
the greatest insults was to bury a human
with a dead animal and in fact many
skeletons have been found buried with
dead animals with missing heads so the
doula Hans headless horse may have come
from this tradition the Dullahan is a
reminder to never lose one's head both
literally and metaphorically
the appearance of a Dullahan often
occurs after the victim has to come to
lustful thoughts or has been drinking
too heavily it serves as a midnight
warning that keeps men and women at home
sober and in their own beds for old
folklore religion and literary history
all have a hand in creating this monster
one of the most terrifying things about
the dullahan
is that it closely resembles the
gruesome realities of medieval Ireland
and combines fact and fiction blurring
reel beheadings with imaginary ones and
you thought the Headless Horseman was
just a Halloween story
[Music]
you
[Music]